I think about the sheer number of people  who pulled together to save my sorry ass  and I can barely comprehend it the cost  of my survival was in the hundreds of  millions of dollars all to save a  botanist with anti-authority issues why  bother  sure part of it might be what I  represent progress science the  interplanetary future we've dreamed  about for centuries but really they  saved me because that's what we do every  human being has a basic instinct to help  each other out if a hiker gets lost in  the mountains people coordinate a search  if an earthquake levels the city people  all over the world send emergency  supplies this instinct is found in every  culture without exception and because of  it I had an entire planet on my side  oh god Neil Armstrong okay right in your  storage shaft a new question for finish  tag but for whom and London before the